salut aujourd'hui on va parler de Grégor
McGregor qui est un aventurier un
imposteur un escroc qui a réussi à
vendre un pays qui n'existe pas voilà
vous savez la femme de l'histoire mais
l'histoire n'est même pas tout aussi
passionnante en réalité il a réussi à
vendre des terres qui n'existaient pas
il a réussi à coloniser une région dans
laquelle il y avait rien à part de la
jungle et des indigènes et tout le monde
s'est fait avoir principalement parce
que l'époque il y avait pas Google Maps
pour vérifier mais avant de commencer
cette vidéo laissez-moi vous parler de
Babel au moment où je sors cette vidéo
vous êtes forcément en train de préparer
un petit peu vos plans pour l'été c'est
peut-être le moment pour se
perfectionner dans une langue soit en
perfectionnant votre vocabulaire dans
cette langue étrangère soit peut-être en
apprenant juste les bases de la langue
qui va se parler dans les pays que vous
allez visiter cet été si vous ne
connaissez pas Babel c'est un service
d'apprentissage de langue ou l'humain
est au cœur de la démarche pour résumer
ma belle fait appel à de vrai
professeurs pour créer les leçons que
vous allez étudier au travers de
l'application mais aussi au travers des
cours qui en direct en ligne il y a
aussi des podcasts il y a même des en
tout c'est 14 langues que vous pouvez
apprendre avec Babel évidemment c'est
pour tous les niveaux mais c'est top
également pour commencer à apprendre du
vocabulaire utile et pratique qui
permettra de d'avoir des échanges
rapidement dans la vie de tous les jours
avec n'importe qui dans n'importe quelle
langue aux quatre coins du Grand le gros
plus de Babel c'est la possibilité de
participer à des cours en live où il y a
maximum 5 élèves qui participent avec le
professeur qui peut du coup donner toute
son attention et le ou la professeur la
langue que vous étudiez c'est sa langue
maternelle c'est vraiment une très bonne
idée de la part de Babel de proposer ça
à savoir qu'avec l'abonnement vous
pouvez participer autant de cours que
vous voulez il n'y a pas il y a pas
vraiment de limite à ça et il y en a
tout au long de la journée pour que tout
le monde puisse en profiter si ça vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à passer par le
lien que je vous ai mis dans la
description parce qu'en plus ce lien là
il vous permet d'avoir une réduction
jusqu'à moins 50% pour les cours en
direct justement sur Babel et sur toute
l'application j'espère que ça vous sera
utile et merci beaucoup à Babel d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo maintenant on
retourne en 1786 en Écosse pour voir la
naissance de Gregor alors gré par
nellaba dans une famille militaire qui
est assez réputée d'ailleurs son son
père est capitaine de la Compagnie des
Indes c'est l'un des capitaines de la
Compagnie des Indes et dans ces ancêtres
par exemple il y a un robe Roy on
l'appelait le Robin des Bois écossais
qu'à participer à des soulèvements
là-bas donc c'est dans cette famille là
qui voit le jour à 16 ans il s'engage
dans l'armée britannique il est
rapidement nommé lieutenant mais Grégor
c'est pas c'est pas un très bon
militaire il est pas très fort parce
qu'il fait par contre il est fort pour
avoir beaucoup d'ambition et en 1805 il
épouse Maria bow water et on pense que
c'est plus par ambition justement que
par amour Maria c'est la fille d'un
amiral de la Navy d'un Amiral qui a
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent et après le
mariage Grégor va se retrouve affilié à
la bourgeoisie se retrouve aussi avec
avec une fortune on va dire confortable
et grâce à cet argent il va acheter son
grade de capitaine ça pouvait se rendre
pour 900 livres à l'époque il représente
quand même pas mal de sous sauf que
malgré ce ne supporte pas tellement
qu'on lui donne des ordres il aime pas
la hiérarchie il a beaucoup de prise de
bec avec ses supérieurs hiérarchiques
dont sont supérieur direct dans l'armée
ça rentre en conflit il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'animosité entre eux et Grégor
va avoir la bonne idée de demander son
renvoi pas lui mais à son supérieur et
hiérarchique c'est pas très bien vu ça à
l'armée et c'est pour ça qu'on va lui
dire de prendre ses affaires et qui va
quitter l'armée en 1810 quoi qu'il en
soit McGregor voulait pas faire car hier
dans l'armée il voulait des choses plus
grands des choses plus ambitieuses dans
sa vie malheureusement en 1801 sa femme
va décéder alors c'est un grand malheur
on l'imagine affectif du moins on espère
qu'il était attaché à elle mais son plus
grand malheur encore c'est que ça le met
dans une précarité financière parce que
toute la fortune à laquelle il avait
accès c'était à la fortune de la famille
de sa femme sa femme n'étant plus là il
a plus le sous il se dit bien tiens je
pourrais épouser encore une riche
héritière mais se dit là
rapidement il va y avoir des soupçons
sur moi et sur mes envies et sur mes
ambitions du coup il faut absolument
trouver une autre idée la fortune qui
lui appartenait pas c'est terminé
l'armée s'est terminée que faire ses
ambitions à son claires il veut gagner
de l'argent mais il faut aussi être
respecté il veut de la reconnaissance il
veut briller et à cette époque là à
Londres ce qui fait un peu classe c'est
quand tu es explorateur et que tu
regardes une contrée lointaine avec des
choses à montrer surtout des choses à
raconter il se dit je vais faire la même
chose et je vais partir au Venezuela
quelques temps c'est ce qui fait arriver
au Venezuela il intègre l'armée de
Francisco Miranda en 1812 là-bas il fait
la rencontre de Josepha Antonia lopéra
qui est la cousine du célèbre
révolutionnaire Simon Bolivar voilà
comme ça vous savez pourquoi la reine
métro s'appelle Simon Bolivar et c'est
pas mal parce que Josepha aller
héritière elle aussi d'une très très
très riche famille de Caracas il
retrouve donc tout ce qu'il avait perdu
en quelques années l'argent un statut
militaire aussi va mener pas mal de
campagnes indépendantes dans les
Caraïbes qui sont des catastrophes en
fait en réalité ils n'hésitent pas à
abandonner ces hommes quand il faut
sauver sa peau il ment aussi sur des
campagnes qui l'auraient faites qui sont
complètement fausses bon c'est toujours
un piètre militaire c'est à cette
période en 1820 qui va faire la
rencontre du roi Georges Frédéric
Augustus le roi des Mosquitos c'est pas
une blague c'est dans le Honduras les
Mosquitos ce sont des descendants des
esclaves africains qui comme les Anglais
n'aiment pas les Espagnols et justement
les Anglais ont profité en fait du fait
que les Mosquitos n'éblaient pas les
Espagnols pour proclamer le roi des
Mosquitos comme ça le roi du Honduras
alors c'est un roi qui avait pas de
pouvoir qui pouvait rien faire etc mais
au moins ça faisait obstacle au
revendications espagnoles et les Anglais
disaient c'est pas à nous mais en fait
il le protégeait et c'est à partir de ce
moment que malgré gore va commencer à
faire des choses mais aujourd'hui on
trouve ça fou moi je trouve ça
hallucinant parce que avant de vendre un
pays qui n'existe pas il va va commencer
par faire comme ça au Honduras c'est une
terre qui est très pauvre il y a pas
beaucoup de pêche c'est pas vraiment
cultivable c'est très compliqué de vivre
là-bas je veux dire il y a de la jungle
partout il y a pas d'infrastructures
modernes et c'est pour ça que le roi
George va accepter de vendre à notre bon
McGregor 8 millions de hacks alors pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée ça fait à
peu près 33000 km², c'est plus grand que
le pays de Galles contre quelques bijoux
et quelques bouteilles de rhum et là le
mec à l'équivalent en surface du Pays de
Galles pour deux taibu et un collier
Grégor donne un nom à cette région qui
vient d'acheter il appelle ça les poyers
puisque les habitants se font appeler
comme ça sauf que qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire de cet endroit je veux dire si
c'est pas cultivable si la pêche allait
pas terrible le mieux c'est de se
débarrasser intelligemment des terres
intelligemment pour au McGregor ça veut
pas forcément dire légalement en 1821
Grégor rentre à Londres avec sa femme et
il se présente comme le quasiq de Poyet
ça veut dire le prince de poignée donc
il est selon lui un délégué du roi qui
vient à tester du couronnement du roi
George IV porter des messages de paix
vis-à-vis de des Anglais et de Londres
et aussi dire que le roi cherche des
immigrants et des investisseurs aussi
pour pour venir sur place ou juste pour
investir dans cette terre où tout est un
peu promis faut vous dire qu'à l'époque
l'Amérique latine elle est en constante
évolution c'est un peu la terre de
toutes les promesses pour ceux qui
veulent faire du business qui veulent
essayer de s'établir une nouvelle vie
sortir de Londres etc donc tout le monde
y croit et toute la haute société de
Londres à l'époque intègre McGregor
comme étant cet explorateur princier
venu rechercher des fonds des
investisseurs et des immigrants qui
voudraient faire le voyage avec lui pour
obtenir des terres là-bas dans le beau
royaume de Poyet le but de Grégor c'est
de vendre des actions et des obligations
de son pays imaginaire le plus vite
possible et donc pour ça il va dire à
tout le monde qu'ils vont avoir un
retour sur investissement très rapide
mais ça suffit pas il faut rendre
l'affaire un peu crédible
et c'est ce qu'il va faire il va créer
tout un système de crédibilité autour il
va commencer par faire un drapeau le
drapeau c'est une croix verte sur fond
blanc il va élaborer un système bancaire
un truc un petit peu complexe il va
aussi imaginer qu'il existe sur place un
système politique avec trois assemblées
législatives tout ça ce sont des
spécificités propres à son pays et il
peut les expliquer et donc plus des
explique plus ça rend la chose réelle il
monte une campagne de com ou les
campagnes de com qui existent
aujourd'hui elles font pas le figure
dire que IP par exemple des gens pour
écrire des chansons à la gloire de plier
et fait chanter ses chansons dans les
rues par des artistes de rue à Glasgow à
Londres un petit peu partout dans le
pays il fait rédiger des articles qui
mettent en avant poliez soit des espèces
de reportages soit au contraire des
choses très très vendeurs c'est très
agressif comme manière de faire il va
publier ça dans tous les magazines sous
forme de dépliant qui vont être insérés
aussi un petit peu partout dans les
journaux de l'époque aussi bien à
Londres que dans tout le pays alors
évidemment il est sollicité pour des
interviews il dit que là-bas on peut y
faire fortune que la vie sur place elle
est douce elle est incroyable ça donne
très envie et là en 1822 il y a quelque
chose d'incroyable qui va changer la
donne il y a un guide à l'usage des
colons qui réappoyaient qui sort et qui
s'intitule je veux pas dire de bêtises
sketch of the mosquito Shore inclusd the
territory of power il est écrit par le
capitaine Thomas Strang the ways
en fait qui a écrit lui-même un guide de
350 pages à destination des personnes
qui veulent immigrer là-bas pour faire
fortune autant vous dire qu'il parle pas
que les terres sont pas cultivables et
qu'il y a pas de poisson sur place il
est écrit je vous cite le climat est
remarquablement sain s'accordant
admirablement avec la constitution des
européens mais aussi que c'est une
destination de spa idéal pour les colons
malades qui peuvent y recouvrir la santé
que le sol est si fertile qu'un
agriculteur peut avoir trois récoltes de
maïs par an au lieu d'une ou cultiver
des cultures de rente comme le sucre ou
le tabac sans aucune difficulté les
poissons et le gibier essentiel pendant
qu'un homme peut chasser ou péché
pendant une journée et ramener
l'équivalent d'une semaine de nourriture
pour toute sa famille c'est pas fini
j'ai pris des notes parce qu'il y a des
choses c'est incroyable les autochtones
ne sont pas seulement coopératifs mais
intensément pro-britannique il a écrit
ça à l'intérieur les autochtones qui ne
pas du tout Londres et les anglais sont
pourtant pro-britanniques la capitale
qui s'appelle Saint Joseph c'est une
ville balnéaire florissante avec de
grands boulevards pavés il n'y a pas eu
de route à Polly les bâtiments à manoir
à colonnes sont habités par 20000
personnes Saint Joseph a également un
théâtre une maison d'opéra une
cathédrale une banque nationale la
maison de Parlement de poignée et
évidemment le palais royal le sketch et
c'est moi qu'on puisse dire aller
jusqu'à prétendre que les rivières de
Poyet contenaient des globules d'or purs
je sais pas ce que c'est un globules
d'or je connais des globules rouges je
connais les pépites d'or mais les
globules d'or pur ça c'est nouveau bon
en tout cas ça marche tout le monde veut
investir dans ce pays parce que c'est
plein d'opportunités donc McGregor vend
des des obligations des actions ils vont
aussi des terres alors les terres ils
vend ça trois schillings nacres je
rappelle qu'il a 8 millions d'accres
trois schillings à l'époque trois
schillings c'est l'équivalent d'une
journée de travail par exemple et la
demande elle est tellement forte qu'il
augmente tout de suite à quatre
schillings pour un acre les gens
dépensent tout leur bien toutes leurs
économies et même beaucoup d'Anglais
vont vendre leurs biens et leur domicile
pour pouvoir acheter plus de terrain
avant de partir là-bas parce qu'avec les
actions et des obligations McGregor
trouve beaucoup d'investisseurs mais ce
qui veut aussi c'est des personnes sur
place on verra pourquoi tout à l'heure
il en trouve pas tant que ça quand même
à Londres donc il va partir en Écosse
comme il est écossais il se dit je vais
savoir leur parler et arriver en Écosse
il explique que voilà il faut absolument
qu'il ait des colons qui viennent parce
que les colons sont des personnes
robustes ils veulent voir payer envahi
de colons pour voir ça ça patrie en fait
directement là-bas que ce soit eux sa
patrie de coeur et de sang qui jouissent
des belles terres de poésie il raconte
n'importe quoi une fois de plus sans
surprise ça va fonctionner Grégor va
donner des emplois fictifs il va signer
des faux contrats de travail là-bas il
invente des emplois complètement bidons
il y en a qui vont être banquiers
d'autres qui vont être facteurs il a
même engager une personne pour devenir
le cordonnier officiel de la princesse
c'est-à-dire la femme de McGregor la
princesse de Poyet il invente tout ça et
il continue même son schéma délirant en
imprimant des phobies de Pollier c'est
des vrais billets mais je veux dire le
pays n'existe pas pour les échanger
contre des livres authentiques là par
contre anglaise alors disons comme ça
voilà arrivé sur place vous êtes déjà de
la monnaie c'est beaucoup plus simple
que de faire du change je vous fais un
bon prix ici enfin il continue à
pigeonner tout le monde en moins d'un an
500 personnes ont acheté des terres à
McGregor il a empoché la petite somme de
200000 livres et il y a tellement de
personnes qui veulent s'y installer en
tant que colon qu'il a de quoi remplir
l'équivalent de 7 navires pour aller
prendre la mer le premier groupe de
colons est prêt à prendre la mer pour
aller pour aller à poiller pour aller
dans le Honduras il se confiés à Hector
hall c'est un ancien officier de l'armée
britannique qui est devenu lieutenant du
gouverneur de Poyet alors il a été nommé
certes mais surtout il a acheté le titre
parce que McGregor d'équipe prendre un
peu de thunes il s'en prive pas le
bateau le Honduras pas quête va prendre
la mer McGregor il va pour le départ il
va pas monter sur le bateau il va juste
saluer un par un l'ensemble des colons
leur souhaiter bon voyage et les
féliciter avant de vous raconter la
suite de l'histoire on peut vraiment se
demander pourquoi il veut envoyer des
personnes là-bas parce que là il a il a
collecté un pactole en livre s'il reste
au Royaume-Uni il risque d'être grillé à
un moment donné il pourrait aussi
essayer de partir en Europe mais il
pourrait aussi tout simplement éviter
d'envoyer des colons il aurait pu juste
faire ça avec des investisseurs pourquoi
pas vous verrez pourquoi tout à l'heure
quatre mois plus tard c'est un deuxième
navire qui part d'Angleterre pour aller
à poiller dans le Honduras là c'est 200
personnes qui vont être dans le bateau
sauf qu'entre temps le premier navire le
Honduras pas quête arrive à polluer et
découvre qui a rien du tout de ce qui a
été raconté par McGregor il y a pas de
ville il y a pas de port il y a pas de
s'il n'y a pas de palais il y a pas tout
ce qu'il aurait été promis et il doute
pas à ce moment là des personnes qui
viennent d'arriver se dit que les
autorités de Polly vont venir les
chercher parce que ils ont dû se planter
d'endroit évidemment il y a pas de GPS à
l'époque hein non plus donc c'est pas si
évident de savoir est-ce qu'on se trouve
donc ils vont vivre sur les rivages dans
des toiles de tente en attendant avec
bon espoir que le gouvernement de police
s'occupe de s'inquiète de leur arrivée
et les retrouves quelques semaines plus
tard le deuxième navire arrive et là on
passe de 50 personnes à 250 personnes
sur le rivage évidemment il y a rien il
fait entre temps il y a tout de suite
une tension qui s'installe entre les
deux groupes parce que par exemple le
deuxième groupe ne comprend pas pourquoi
Hector hall n'a pas lancé durant ces
quelques semaines qu'ils étaient sur
place à construction de bâtiments de
d'abris un petit peu plus solides le
souci c'est que d'une part il pense à
rester et d'autre part parmi les colons
qui ont été envoyés personne n'a les
compétences de construction de pour
défricher quelque part pour créer un
abri ça jamais été le dans ce voyage
donc ils ont pas été sélectionnés par
leurs compétences comme ça se faisait
beaucoup quand on envoyait des colons
sur l'île Vierge au bout d'un moment
pour Hector hall c'est clair McGregor
les a trompés et il va commencer à
expliquer ce raisonnement là à toutes
les personnes sur la page 249 autres
personnes mais personne ne le croit
enfin personne ne croit une partie
commence à se méfier mais la majorité se
dit c'est pas possible on n'a pas pu
être trompé à ce point et ça c'est un
principe psychologique qui existe encore
aujourd'hui celui de la dissonance
cognitive les personnes faut bien se
rappeler qu'elles ont vendu leur bien
leur maison elles ont mis leur économie
elles ont fait un voyage à risque à
disant tout quitter c'est très dur
d'accepter que tu t'es fait avoir à ce
moment là tu t'y ben non pas après tout
ce qu'on a engagé et puis en plus il y a
cette espèce d'autorité naturelle que
forme le groupe tu dis ok moi je me suis
fait avoir mais là les 249 autres celui
qui est issu de l'armée britannique et
qui est maintenant lieutenant du
gouverneur de Poyet lui aussi s'est fait
avoir
déclaré impossible en fait et ça évite
de décompenser mentalement et de tomber
dans une grosse dépression que de que
d’être dans le déni c'est plus simple à
vivre psychologiquement pour autant le
moral va quand même se tasser on va dire
un petit peu dans l'équipe sur le rivage
déjà parce que la saison des pluies
arrive ils vont commencer par se faire
attaquer par les moustiques les vivres
commencent à
se dépérir un petit peu ou simplement à
disparaître aussi parce que ils mangent
plus ils consomment plus que ce qu'ils
arrivent à récolter par la cueillette ou
par la pêche et il y a des personnes qui
commencent aussi à tomber malade du
paludisme de la malariade ce genre de
choses c'est pourquoi Hector hall un
moment donné se dit ok je vais partir en
expédition et je vais essayer de trouver
le roi le roi Augustus le roi donc du
Honduras ou du moins celui qu'on appelle
à l'époque le roi des Mosquitos Hector
hall part en expédition et pendant ce
temps-là dans la semaine qui vont suivre
toutes les personnes restées sur le
rivage vont être découverts enfin par le
navire qui s'appelle le Mexican Eagle
qui va voir toutes ces tentes sur le
rivage et qui va aller qui va aller
mouiller l'encre pour aller les
rencontrer c'est le maréchal Bennett qui
est le capitaine de navire il demande
qu'il est responsable un petit peu de ce
campement on lui explique c'est
quelqu'un qui est parti en expédition et
on lui explique aussi tout l'histoire et
là Bennett va révéler que tout ça c'est
une supercherie parce que Bennett c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui habite dans le
Honduras britannique donc le American
Eagle c'est un bateau du Honduras
britannique donc il explique que Polly
n'a jamais existé qu'ils ont jamais
entendu parler de McGregor alors il
propose d'emmener tout le monde déjà en
Duras britannique pour qu'il puisse être
pris en charge et qui reste pas comme ça
assez étrangement la plupart d'entre eux
préfèrent rester sur le rivage et
attendre le retour de Hector hall
on en a parlé c'est là que vous allez
aimer parce que tout va s'accélérer
Hector hall revient en groupement
quelques jours après avec le roi
Augustus qui découvre du coup la
supercherie qui révèle au colon qui n'a
jamais accordé à McGregor le titre de
kazi de Prince ni même le fait d'avoir
le droit de vendre ses terres ou de
louer cet air ou de faire des
investissements ce genre de choses
d'ailleurs il révoque immédiatement
toutes les terres qu'il avait concédé
contre le rhum et les bijoux à McGregor
mais c'est un effet c'est un effet
délétère puisque du coup les 250
personnes se retrouvent immédiatement
sur les terres du roi de façon
complètement illégale heureusement
Bennett est toujours là sur le ridage
avec son bateau donc la plupart des gens
vont partir avec Bennett obélise et la
Grande-Bretagne va être informé de cette
affaire juste à temps parce qu'au moment
où la Grande-Bretagne est informée de ce
qui se passe là-bas McGregor est en
train de remplir 5 navires d'un coup qui
vont partir direction payer la finalité
elle est pas heureuse sur les 250
personnes qui qui en naviguait jusqu'à
ce pays imaginaire de Poyet la plupart
sont morts 180 d'entre eux 50 seulement
sans retourner en Angleterre ça fait
balschiffre mais on a perdu la trace
d'une vingtaine de personnes qui sont
sûrement rester en endurance britannique
ce sachant des masqués McGregor va fuir
en France où il va essayer de reproduire
la même escroquerie en pendant ces
terres là-bas sauf que évidemment au
lieu de dire que c'est une royauté il
dit que c'est une république il s'adapte
à son marché seulement ça va moins bien
se passer parce que les aspirants colons
français vont demander des passeports
pour pouvoir aller à poiller McGregor va
fournir les passeport ce qui va
permettre à la France de faire une
enquête là-dessus et de constater que ce
pays n'existe pas c'est à cet instant ou
McGregor va être enfin arrêté mais là
c'est un peu fou parce qu'on dit que le
crime ne paie pas
dans le cas de McGregor c'est pas aussi
évident il est incarcéré en prison le 7
décembre 1825 il va être jugé en juillet
1826 où il va être acquitté étrangement
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour qu'il
soit quitté on sait pas tellement en
tout cas il rentre à Londres il se
prétend toujours quasi là-bas donc c'est
à dire prince quand même sauf que là
évidemment personne ne le croit donc il
se passe rien pour lui alors il va aller
au Venezuela et il y arrive en 1839 à
partir de ce moment là il va toucher
là-bas une retraite comme ancien général
souvenez-vous il avait acheté son titre
à l'époque quand il avait rencontré
cette femme de riche famille et au final
il va y vivre plutôt tranquille une vie
paisible là-bas au Venezuela jusqu'en
1845 où les décédé et jusqu'au genre de
son décès il aura jamais été reconnu
coupable de ses crimes ni inquiéter pour
eux évidemment c'est d'autres époques
d'autres meurt ceci on se dit ben voilà
il y a pas le regroupement des
informations qu'on a aujourd'hui avec
avec les numériques avec les ordinateurs
avec Internet
mais c'est fou quand même qu'il soit ça
qui s'en soit sorti à ce point j'ai fait
des recherches sur le sujet je trouve
qu'il manque des pans pourquoi il était
acquitté comment il a pu repartir si
facilement à Londres comment il a repu
quitté l'ombre pour aller au Venezuela
alors que quand même il y a des gens qui
avaient perdu les 180 personnes qui ont
péri de maladie etc ils avaient bien des
familles en Angleterre est-ce qu'il
avait encore beaucoup de finances et
qu'il a pu acheter aussi l'influence de
certains ou les décisions de justice des
autres le fait qu'il ait touché nos
retraites au Venezuela c'est pas si
étonnant parce que même s'il avait
acheté le titre il était quand même
ancien général là-bas pour autant encore
une fois ces expéditions les savait
souvent mensongères on savait qu'il
avait abandonné ces hommes il y a quand
même des zones d'ombre et de mystères
sur sur comment il a pu faire ça comment
il a pu inventer ce pays de poyé comment
il a pu vendre autant d'actions
d'obligations sans être inquiéter pour
ça c'est à dire que malheureusement
c'est parfois le cas dans le capitalisme
si tu t'occupes pas les humains par
contre tu t'occupes parfois de tes
ressources financières donc si on s'est
pas posé la question sur les morts et
sur les colons qui étaient partis les
investisseurs auraient pu demander quand
même réparation pour ses actions ces
obligations sur des terres qui
n'existaient pas tout ça ça a été assez
enfoui si vous en savez plus que moi je
serais très curieux de lire ça dans la
description n'hésitez pas à mettre à
mettre des sources sur le sujet mais je
pense que je serai pas le seul à les
lire avec plaisir merci encore à Babel
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à passer par eux pour apprendre une
langue qui vous servira dans un pays qui
existe vraiment si ça vous intéresse
n'oubliez pas que vous avez le lien dans
la description qui vous permet d'avoir
une réduction spéciale jusqu'à moins 50%
pour tous les cours en direct sur Babel
et à toute l'application également et
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette
histoire à la belle-mère ce all Sud
c'était une histoire un peu dézoomée
puisqu'on a voyagé un peu partout à
travers le monde n'oubliez pas de
toujours en spectacle encore pour
quelques représentations pour cette
première saison de mon spectacle de
mentalisme du Moore et qui a la date du
22 novembre 2023 à la Salle Pleyel à
Paris ce sera la seule représentation à
Paris en 2023 pour une version très
spéciale là vous voyez les places qui
restent je vous mets aussi un lien dans
la description pour réserver la vôtre à
très bientôt Ciao